Speaker 1: Kyle Rittenhouse was found not
guilty of criminal charges for killing multiple
people at his criminal trial, but is now being
sued by the family of one of the men he shot
dead in 2020 and by Gaige Grosskreutz as well,
whom he injured.
Kyle Rittenhouse is begging, just begging
people on Tucker Carlson's show, Send me money
because it's so unfair what they're doing
to me.
The funniest part, and this really is funny
when the time comes for Rittenhouse to give
the URL where you can donate to him, he mangles
the URL.
This is the whole reason he was on the show.
Check this out.
Speaker 3: No idea.
Speaker 1: I mean, just to be.
Let me explain one other thing.
He's being sued civilly.
Remember, you can be found criminally not
guilty by the standard of reasonable doubt
and then responsible civilly for the same
death of an individual that you caused.
So just remember that that he's being sued
civilly now.
Speaker 3: No idea.
It's it's ridiculous.
This lawsuit is very frustrating and it's
upsetting this, frustratingly to me, an attack
on our Second Amendment rights and our rights
to self-defense.
Right.
And it's saying if you use your God given
right to self-defense, they're going to come
after you.
If you win in court, you're acquitted, rightfully
so.
They're going to take you to civil court and
they're going to file.
They're going to take you for everything you're
worth.
They're going to drive you into bankruptcy
and drown you in a mountain of legal bills.
And I know we're going to win the court, but
it's going to be expensive.
It's going to cost a lot of money to fight.
These attorneys are very powerful.
You can go to WW dot Gibson goal.com.
Speaker 1: Oc WW dot giv sun go dot com.
I have no clue what the hell that is outside
court.
Speaker 3: Rent a house to help me.
Speaker 1: Let's hear it once more.
Speaker 3: Attorneys are very powerful.
You can go to WW dot Gibson go Rt.com for
psychiatry house give.
Speaker 1: Go.
Speaker 3: To help me take on these lawyers
so they don't come after more people because
if they can come after me, they will come
after you.
Speaker 1: Right.
Will they, though?
I'm not sure about that.
Why would they come up?
Why would they come after people who haven't
done what Kyle Rittenhouse chose to do?
So here's the deal with this.
He wants you to think that if he's been acquitted
criminally, it's unfair that you should be
able to be sued civilly.
But that's just how the system works.
You know, these these people talk about respect
for law and order and all of it.
This is the way it works.
Criminal law deals with crimes considered
harmful to society as a whole murder, theft,
assault, etc.
Criminal law would punish offenders, deter
others from committing similar crimes in some
theoretical sense, rehabilitate.
Okay, it doesn't happen too often.
Criminal cases are initiated by the government.
The burden of proof is on the prosecution
to prove the defendant's guilt beyond a reasonable
doubt.
If you're found guilty, you might have fines,
imprisonment or other forms of punishment.
The modern legal system we have is based on
common law developed in England, adopted in
many countries like the United States, and
it also includes civil law.
This is a bedrock foundation of our legal
system.
He might not like it, but it is.
And when there are disputes between individuals,
could be a contractual dispute, could be a
personal injury claim, which is what we're
talking about here.
The purpose of civil law is cases brought
by a plaintiff to compensate an injured party
for the suffer the harm that they suffered.
And civil cases are initiated by the injured
party, not the government.
It's a different burden, which is a preponderance
of evidence, sort of like thinking about 51%
likely.
That's not actually the way lawyers would
describe it, but it is a different standard
and you can be found not guilty criminally.
And responsible civilly.
If you support law and order, if you claim,
as Kyle Rittenhouse does, to support all of
these different aspects of our system, this
is part of the system.
And you can't pick and choose, which is all
they want to do.
He doesn't like it.
He also doesn't understand it.
Similar when Trump said, How can they impeach
me again?
They already impeach me.
Well, for something different.
Or how can they impeach me when Mueller cleared
me?
Well, Mueller didn't clear you of obstruction,
but it has nothing to do with the Mueller
probe, has nothing to do with whether you
can be impeached.
They would like things to work differently
than they do.
But this is it.
Pathetic.
Kyle Rittenhouse now begging for money and
you can go to a URL I couldn't even understand.
I guess if you want
to donate,